[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je propose d'écouter l'analyse de
pierre deval il est avocat au barreau de
paris
transformer radicalement le monde de la
justice c'est évidemment un augmenter
les budgets mais les augmenter de façon
colossale et c'est ce que le ministre de
la justice a entre ses mains
visiblement 2c modifier le statut du
parquet est encore une fois cela fait à
peu près consensus 3 c'est réfléchir sur
les questions de la réforme de
l'instruction et d'information
judiciaire parce que les juges
d'instruction croule sous les dossiers
et dispose de moyens d'action qui ne
sont pas à la hauteur de la tâche qui
est la leur vous savez balzac disait le
juge d'instruction est l'homme le plus
puissant de france et bien cette réalité
a traversé le temps pour venir jusqu'à
nous et aujourd'hui les juges
d'instruction malgré leur bonne volonté
ils sont totalement dépassées par le
nombre de dossiers par les moyens encore
une fois qu'ils sont insuffisants donc
ça c'est une piste de réflexion
également on peut envisager la question
de la transformation de l' enquête
préliminaire avec une introduction de
davantage de contradictoire la
possibilité pour les avocats d'accéder à
davantage d'éléments de la procédure la
question de la durée vous voyez tout
cela en vrac bien sûr mais vous avez de
grandes pistes de réflexion qui peuvent
être engagées et encore une fois les
linéaments principal de cette réflexion
ça doit être le budget